[Music]
Secret Service sex scandal keeps growing
it more unfolds every day here's the
latest three of the Secret Service
agents involved in the sex and cocaine
scandal are now leaving the agency yeah
on the bright side they're gonna have
one hell of a going-away party
[Applause]
does anybody do this anymore
does anybody here raise the roof be
honest no no that's sarcastic now that
there's nothing worse than a sarcastic
is the roof I think was more pity than
circuit that was pity yeah that was
holding up the wall which is different
yesterday one of the prostitutes
involved in the Secret Service scandal
said an agent offered her only $30 for
an $800 sex act yeah yeah parently the
Secret Service's secret is that they are
cheap bastards you know I'm curious
what's an $800 sex I know our period
costumes involved they better be 300
bucks it's in Colombia yeah I bet that
dollar goes law or going further down
yeah sure I don't know I just very
curious
well the weekend's coming up you could
check it out again White Supreme Court
finally tackling the real issues the
Supreme Court is finally gonna hear a
case about Janet Jackson flashing her
breasts at the 2004 Super Bowl yeah of
course it's been eight years so her
breasts no longer hold up in court
[Applause]
[Music]
that's just me actually holding up the
breasts now
classy show good show hope you're
watching with your children you all
remember the JetBlue pilot who went
little cuckoo recently the JetBlue pilot
who was arrested after a mid-air
meltdown last month will plead that he
was temporarily insane which explains a
jet blues new slogan don't worry our
pilots are only temporarily insane
that'll put you at ease on tape
a group of parents is suing Apple for
deliberately designing apps to be
addictive
for children yeah today a lawyer for
Apple entered a plea of duh Time
magazine has named its 100 most
influential people yeah actually it's
just a list of the hundred people who
still subscribed to Time magazine
[Applause]
oh there goes my subscription Japanese
researchers have successfully grown hair
on a bald Mouse yeah yeah the
researchers are ecstatic and the mouse
is relieved he doesn't have to keep
wearing that stupid toupee
my mother wrote that one is that what
are killing you to have a cute joke yeah
apparently yes
here in Los Angeles haha a maintenance
worker has been arrested for placing
hidden cameras inside fitting rooms at
Sears yeah the cameras revealed some
really embarrassing footage women in
Sears clothing
[Applause]
[Music]
and then this is amazing yesterday
ladies and gentlemen the world's oldest
man turned 115 yeah yeah when asked what
he missed most about his youth the man
said hosting Larry King Live
[Applause]
[Music]
and then motorboat back in
didn't see that one coming did you